so what's the big deal well US president
Donald Trump says it's simple really his
plan for Israel and Palestine is the
best deal out there and the Palestinians
need to realize that this could be the
last opportunity they will ever have but
can we even call it a deal the
Palestinians say it's more like a done
deal or no deal at all
you know what wait if I should so how
does Trump's plan stack up against the
ones that have failed before and does it
stand any chance at all of ending more
than a hundred years of mistrust and war
before we do a deep dive on the Trump
pun let's remind ourselves how we got
into this mess
first off there's Jerusalem over the
centuries Jews Muslims and Christians
have fought over their holy city
religiously but they've also fought over
the promised land who does it belong to
go back far enough and all three can
stake a claim Israel is trying to carve
out a home here and the Palestinians are
trying to hold on to theirs and it's
this fight that Trump has stepped into
with a new plan to solve things many
have tried before him and just as many
have failed in the fight to give the
Jews their own country 1917 was big it's
when Arthur James Balfour the UK's
Foreign Secretary promised the Jewish
people a national home in Palestine this
was the map back then but it's been
changing ever since and Wars have had a
lot to do with that the time is the
summer of 1948 a turning point in
history for the people of Palestine the
promised land the arab-israeli war in
1948 was won by Jewish militias who took
over a lot of land three-quarters of a
million Palestinians lost everything
it's what they call the Nakba the
catastrophe of the modular bad macGruber
Jericho elevated the Hanoverian Arab
youth now after the arab-israeli war the
borders changed from this to
in 1967 the Six Day War ended in
Israel's military occupation of the West
Bank and the Gaza Strip but that didn't
settle things Israel continued to expand
the Palestinians fought back in the
cycle got stuck on repeat the 1990s on
the Oslo Accords brought a brief moment
of hope the first one signed in 1993 was
historic sworn enemies shaking hands on
the White House lawn
those two even won a Nobel Peace Prize
but the terms of the Oslo Accords failed
to stick cue another attempt the 2002
Arab Peace Initiative this time
countries that belong to the Arab League
told Israel to end its occupation of
Palestinian land but Israel wasn't
interested and those are just the
highlights in a string of failed deals
so let's take a look at what they're
fighting over it's this land between the
river Jordan and the Mediterranean Sea
today it's carved up by Israeli
settlements and guarded by separation
walls the process that we've been
gradually since 1967 is this process in
which Israel is gradually over taking
steam baths building settlements
demographically re-engineering advancing
its interests at the expense of the
rights of Palestinians
[Applause]
something had to be done and as soon as
Donald Trump got to the White House he
figured he could pull it off
he put his son-in-law Jared Kushner in
charge of coming up with a two-state
solution Israel and Palestine
side-by-side three years later Kushner
presented a plan that he says includes
major Israeli concessions this is the
first time that Israel has ever agreed
to a Palestinian state and it's the
first time that Israel has agreed to a
map and so this is an amazing
opportunity for the Palestinian
leadership and they'd be very wise to
pursue it it's a great plan for Israel
it's a great plan for peace so what
Kushner in Israel are basically saying
is this Israel isn't giving up any of
its land occupied or otherwise and as
far as the Palestinians are concerned he
says they need to know that any deal is
better than no deal at all
but if you ask the Palestinians well
actually no one asks the Palestinians
they call it a deal except the party
that they want to make a deal with is
not even at the table one reason is that
the Palestinians have basically cut off
all ties with the Americans that goes
back to 2017 when Trump decided to
recognize Jerusalem as the capital of
Israel and moved the US Embassy there
the Palestinians were incensed they've
always seen East Jerusalem as theirs so
let's look at what the Americans and
Israelis came up with it's all in this
180 one-page document called peace to
prosperity it includes a 50 billion
dollar infrastructure plan international
investors are expected to pay for it and
it's supposed to create a million jobs
for Palestinians while reducing poverty
but the Palestinians say money won't buy
their support for a deal they haven't
agreed to one of the big issues is
Israeli settlements considered illegal
under international law Israel says it's
agreed to stop building them in occupied
territories like the West Bank for the
next four years but here's the thing
there are already 200 settlements with
600,000 Israelis living in them under
Trump's plan they would all be annexed
as part of Israel and critics say that
just rewards Israel for breaking the law
if there's one lesson we can gain from
the last you know 50 plus years of
building settlements is the level of
Israeli commitment to continue going at
that project on Jerusalem the deal says
the city remains the undisputed capital
of Israel it also says that Palestine
gets part of East Jerusalem just not the
part the Palestinians want to Jerusalem
they're offering is is on the outskirts
and don't even fall within international
lines of what's recognized as East
Jerusalem which includes the old city of
Jerusalem where all the holy sites are
and finally Palestinian refugees can
forget about going home to the land
they've lost the deal says there shall
be no right of return this was entirely
missing and I think future peace
negotiations will continue to fail
unless that vital ingredient of Rights
is present and after all that if this
plan ever makes it this is what the two
states would look like Palestine would
be a patchwork of territories joined by
tunnels and bridges surrounded by a sea
of Israeli settlements roads and
separation walls Israel would control
the borders and airspace and look at the
Gaza Strip nearly 2 million Palestinians
live there in almost complete isolation
and poverty they're being promised a 50
kilometer long rail tunnel to the West
Bank one of the longest in the world the
enola
[Music]
it doesn't offer them stated attractive
offers them the permanent state of
apartheid so if the palestinians aren't
sold why are Trump and Netanyahu pushing
this now many analysts say the timing of
this plan wasn't a coincidence both
leaders were heading into an election
Trump was facing impeachment and on the
day they announced the deal Netanyahu
was in
on corruption charges so it's very
convenient that this plan has come at
this point Trump in Netanyahu's plan
also seems like it has the backing of
Arab states like Saudi Arabia who are
encouraging Palestine to negotiate this
is all in a sort of context of a
regional political shift in which these
Arab states are allowing themselves and
entrench in their relationships with
Israel and the u.s. so you get the idea
the proportions of this conflict are
biblical as is the scale of suffering in
this small corner of the world no plan
not even this one from Trump and the
Israelis offers us someone or even a
two-state solution that they can all
agree on what we have is more like a
state of confusion start your episodes
are your primers to understand the world
of news but of course there's so much
more to every story particularly when it
comes to Israel and Palestine so do go
to al-jazeera comm where you can find
all sorts of Interactive's and features
that will get you an even deeper insight
into what's going on I'll see you next
week